[Musique]
on en fait des montagnes immense où les
brasiers qui ne s'éteignent jamais
2 solution imparfaite un problème qui
revient tous les jours celui des déchets
ceux qui n'ont pas trouvé leur place
dans le bac de recyclage
né dans le bac à compost ce qu'on en pin
sur les trottoirs et qui disparaissent
de nos vies comme par magie
[Musique]
l'incinération ce n'est pas de la magie
et l'enfouissement ne les fait pas
disparaître
prenez le temps de regarder ce sont vos
déchets médicaux
au québec chacun nous en génère 700 kg
par année c'est presque un record
mondial et c'est un chiffre qu'on arrive
plus à faire diminuer le plus triste
c'est que la majorité de ces déchets
n'en sont pas
est ce qu'on peut continuer à tout
enfouir devrait-on faire plus de place à
l'incinération
mais surtout comment mettre nos sacs
noirs au régime
ces questions québec les a confié il ya
un an au bureau d'audiences publiques
sur l'environnement mardi prochain le
bas va remettre ses conclusions au
gouvernement provincial ce sera une
feuille de route pour guider nos choix
des vingt prochaines années ce soir nous
vous invitons à découvrir les coulisses
de notre gestion des déchets à commencer
par l'enfouissement
à moins d'habiter à côté les sites
d'enfouissement sont loin des yeux est
souvent loin du coeur pourtant ce sont
des montagnes de déchets qui grandit à
vue d'oeil et qui vont rester là pour
toujours
et ça a des conséquences sur l'eau mais
surtout sur l'atmosphère et sur le
climat le rôle d'un site d'enfouissement
c'est minimiser les impacts de nos
déchets
pour nous montrer comment elle s'y prend
l'entreprise waste management nouveau
ouvert les portes d'un de ses sites
celui de sainte sophie dans les
laurentides
on y reçoit un million de tonnes de
déchets par année ce qui en fait un des
plus gros de la province
au total au québec on enfouit plus de 5
millions tonnes de déchets par plusieurs
petits sites en région et quelques très
gros autour des villes
la première chose qu'on constate c'est
que l'enfouissement a bien évolué depuis
l'époque des dépotoirs
allez trouver un secteur
on est vraiment
[Musique]
gislais lacombe dirige toute une armée
d'ingénieurs et de techniciens
de nos jours un site d'enfouissement
c'est un chantier perpétuel avec deux
grandes obligations traiter l'eau
contaminées par les déchets et capter
les gaz
le site de sainte sophie est exploitée
depuis 1964 mais une cellule à la fois
une cellule chez nous c'est ce qu'on a
besoin pour maintenir nos opérations
pendant une année donc ce que vous voyez
derrière moi ce une cellule qu'on a
construit de cette année superficie
d'environ 5 hectares c'est ce qu'on va
avoir besoin pour maintenir nos
opérations jusqu'à mai prochain
ghislain lacombe comparé ces cellules à
des zips locke
d'immenses sacs de plastique avec un
fond pour capter l'eau contaminée est un
couvercle pour retenir les gaz
à coup d'une cellule par année le
travail n'arrête jamais pour briguer
réel qui supervise les travaux et pas de
temps mort tout à fait y'a pas de temps
mort on va pas attendre que une cellule
arriva capacités pour pour démarrer la
séance séquence pour beaucoup tout bien
géré
cette séquence commence par le fonds qui
creusé dans l'argile avec une légère
pente pour éviter que l'eau s'accumule
la présente on est dans le fond de la
selle sur la couche d'argile et là on
voit bien les carnations était un fait
de sorte à ce que le point bas qui se
trouve plus à l'ouest fait que l'eau et
se dirige vers le point bas sur l'argile
il y aura plusieurs couches de
protection
l'objectif c'est de retenir le lixiviats
qui est à la fois l'eau des déchets
eux-mêmes mais aussi la pluie ou la
neige tombe sur les déchets pendant
qu'ils sont exposés et il ne doit pas
atteindre la nappe phréatique
dans l'ordre on installe sur ampli
d'argile une membrane de plastique un
grillage et une autres membres anne
c'est sur elle que le lixiviats va se
déplacer et pour protéger les membranes
une couche de feutre et 50 centimètres
de pierre avant de mettre des déchets
l'objectif de fond sérieux c'est d'être
complètement étanche ce terrain
fonctionne mais qui accumule point d'eau
autrement dit l'eau
des canalisations souterraines amène
tous les liquides des cellules vers cet
immense bassin c'est là que commence le
travail de marc andré loisel celui de
retirer un maximum de contaminants et
beaucoup de polluants mais
principalement au niveau biologique
c'est l'azoté ammoniacal très fortes
concentrations en azote au niveau des
métaux faut qu'on enlève le zinc mais
d'autres métaux le plomb le mercure des
choses comme ça qu'on peut pas juste
laissé aller à l'environnement on
pourrait pas se faire ce serait
catastrophique
le traitement des buts dans ces deux
bâtiments dans le plus ancien l'odeur
prend la gorge c'est un réservoir 7
mètres de profondeur où on brasse en
permanence le lixiviats actuellement
en débile mais l'être minutes puis on
s'en remet il est revenu de manière
continue
le lixiviats contient des bactéries qui
vont se nourrir de l'azoté ammoniacal et
le transformer en nitrites et en
nitrates des formes d'azoté moins
nocives en ajoutant de l'oxygène on
accélère le travail des bactéries
l'étape suivante c'est une série de
filtres qui retiennent les matières en
suspension et qui laisse passer les
liquides
liquid de la plus grassement bras mais
on appelle le permet au cerveau vers
l'enlèvement des métaux la note au
troisième il comme on peut voir les yeux
plus de l'epu des matières en suspension
et fois debout à paris
donc le processus biologique fini à
partir de fin octobre
la touche finale c'est de faire
précipiter sous forme solide les métaux
lourds comme le zinc le plomb ou le
mercure l'eau qui reste est ensuite
rejetée dans un ruisseau
on n'est pas potable mais selon les
normes et nous sortir de notre
certificat d'autorisation émis par le
ministère on respecte nos engagements en
plus des normes provinciales le
ministère donne à chaque site des
objectifs spécifiques à atteindre celui
de sainte sophie doit réduire ses
nitrates qui contribuent au
dépérissement des lacs et des rivières
waste management se donne deux ans pour
le faire
le deuxième grand défi des sites
d'enfouissement c'est de gérer les gaz
parce que certains déchets se décompose
ce que je nage le biogaz c'est toute la
matière organique donc on parle de tout
ce qui est fruit végétaux que ça peut
être des bouts organique ou si qu'on
reçoit ça peut être la pelouse ça peut
être des feuilles tout toutes matières
organiques qui qui est enfoui pikine en
absence d'oxygène voix générer du
méthane et le méthane c'est un problème
pour la planète parce que c'est un gaz à
effet de serre
il va être captées de deux manières
différentes
quand la cellule est en exploitation on
ajoute des déchets le jour et le soir on
les recouvre
tous les deux trois mois on installe les
tuyaux perforés pour aspirer les gaz
à la montagne atteint son altitude
maximale les déchets sont recouverts de
nouvelles membranes qui fusionner avec
celle d'en dessous le ziploc protège les
déchets de l'eau mais aussi de l'oxygène
à l'intérieur la production de méthane
accélère des tuyaux à la verticale vont
permettre à la pression de sortir
c'est là qu'intervient un outil dingue
la science fiction
la foreuse à déchets elle va creuser à
différentes profondeurs pour installer
des tuyaux entouré trial
ses tuyaux pouvant servir depuis
ils seront sous la responsabilité de
ghislain le court je connais bien chacun
d'eux
[Musique]
présente mal est un très très bon puis
ce sens que je fais j'ai longuement pour
aller chercher le lait le maximum de
méthane dans l'eau
pendant des dizaines d'années les
déchets font produire du méthane qui le
même case que dans le gaz naturel
gérer un site d'enfouissement c'est
aussi exploiter un champ gazier avec 300
puits qui siphonnent le site en
permanence
tous les biogaz qui sont pompés du site
sont acheminés dans neuf bâtiments ici
avec nos cycles en
c3 six langues qui aspect qui crée un
vacuum dans la masse de déchets je vous
dirais environ 15 mille mètres cubes à
leur
demande en eau dans nos contrées c'est
beaucoup c'est énorme c'est non un
gazoduc part du site d'enfouissement et
se dirige vers l' usine de papier roland
à saint-girons le biogaz remplace le gaz
naturel il fournit la chaleur nécessaire
pour faire sécher tout le papier produit
par l'usiné et il en reste
l'excédent environ 40% et brûlé par des
torchères la combustion produit du co2
qui est aussi au gaz à effet de serre
mais beaucoup moins puissante le méthane
cette obligation de capter le méthane et
de minimalement le détruire c'est le
résultat des grandes consultations que
le bape avait mené il ya 25 ans
[Musique]
mais il y a un mais et même deux les
petits sites de moins de 100 mille
tonnes n'ont pas à le faire et les plus
gros même bien équipée n'arrive pas à
tout capté
dont on parle à un coût 90 au captage
environ 95% une fois qu'on a omis les
recouvrements finale en place de la
géomembrane cancon un front déchets
ouvert c'est-à-dire que ou qu'on a les
activités de réception de compactage des
matières rizzo l'on parle à peu près à
80 85 % donc de façon générale on parle
à un taux qui varie 1 à peu près en
moyens 90%
avec le méthane qui s'échappent le
secteur des déchets représente à lui
seul 5,8 pour cent des gaz à effet de
serre au québec
reste que l'enfouissement c'est une
solution simple et peu coûteuse pour
gérer la quantité astronomique de
déchets congénères mais c'est une
solution imparfaite
le mandat que le bape a reçu c'est de
réfléchir aux vingt prochaines années et
d'évaluer si c'est encore la voie à
suivre
pour cette sophie s'est réglé ou presque
le site a reçu le feu vert pour
développer un nouveau secteur 1 million
de tonnes de déchets par année jusqu'en
et tout indique qu'il va falloir
agrandir les autres sites ou même en
ouvrir de nouveau à moins de changer
radicalement de cap
que ce soit en autriche en république
tchèque au danemark
les incinérateurs dernier cri se
multiplier bien des pays considèrent que
c'est une façon de valoriser les déchets
que c'est meilleur pour la planète
mais ici c'est vu comme une approche
archaïque québec est une des rares
villes qui brûle encore ces déchets
ainsi sur calais ce narrateur et tous
méconnu il ya beaucoup de citoyens
et ceux qui en ont entendu parler c'est
probablement en mal à cause la pollution
qu'ils aimaient richard laramée aimerait
qu'on parle aussi des avantages de
l'incinération mais avant il fallait
régler certains problèmes parce que
c'est un équipement plutôt vieillissent
les stars adorent date 74 exception que
comme n'importe quelle épreuve structure
qui date d'un certain nombre d'année
battent il faut l'entretenir donc ya de
l'argent à merde ce qui a été fait ces
dernières années
en 2015 la ville a repris du privé la
gestion sur l'incinérateur et a choisi
de le moderniser des investissements
touche à la fois la combustion et les
systèmes de traitement des fumées avec
un même objectif rejeter moins de
contaminants dans l'air l'incinérateur
est en plein coeur de la ville qu'il
s'agisse de résidence ou de commerce
tous les déchets de québec finissent
dans cette trappe et il se retrouve ici
à chaque année on fout environ 245
milles tonnes de déchets sur la 52ème
donc un petit peu moins 5000 tonnes par
semaine
la fosse à déchets est tellement grande
qu'on perd le sens des proportions mais
en 2 ou 3 pincées le grappin déplace
l'équivalent d'un camion complète
déchets
j'ai cinq tonnes par péter environ 110
sera uniformisé carburant dans la fosse
à des chiens passé de s'alimenter les
ponts c'est vraiment le plus parce qu'il
faut comprendre que les déchets des
foires et plus humide des fois moins
humide évidemment la seule à avoir une
unité le plus uniforme possible pour que
la confiance soit le plus constante
possible est au rendez vous
jean pierre alexandre bessette parle de
four ça porte un peu à confusion parce
que ce ne sont pas les fours qui
fournissent la chaleur mais ce qu'on met
dans les déchets brûle demain ça dégage
énormément d'énergie d'ailleurs quand on
s'approche des portes on sent la chaleur
radiante qui savent qu'ils dégagent des
faux le défi c'est de s'assurer que les
déchets brûlés à la bonne température
si la température chute la combustion
est incomplète on aimait alors du
monoxyde de carbone c'est au pied des
faces pour la santé en restant au dessus
de 800 degrés celsius on produit du co2
ce qui est un moindre mal
800 degrés c est sûr c'est qu'on va être
capable d'oxyder le monoxyde de carbone
peut en générer du co2 paramètres pour
lequel les normes son poleman en fait le
monoxyde de carbone en limite qu'on doit
pas dépasser et puis c'est quand même
c'est quand même pas nés samaras et ça
demande une bonne combustion
pour y arriver les opérateurs peuvent
répartir les déchets humides entre les
quatre fours et contrôler l'oxygène qui
y entrent mais leur nouvel outil ce sont
des brûlures au gaz naturel
noir et armés
ils peuvent être allumées au besoin pour
fournir une chaleur d'appoint qui fait
qu'on va rang des émissions au bout du
compte c'est la qualité de la conviction
et les brûlures au gaz naturel nous
permettre de maintenir une température
idéale pour pouvoir avoir le meilleur
de moi des puretés possible dans les
gares et de mieux traiter ce qui va
sortir ou cheminée avant de sortir aux
cheminées les gaz sont traités dans
l'autre partie du sinn et ici c'est le
système de distribution du charbon qui a
été modernisée
c'est tellement ion faible d'un
processus assez complexe
il y a d'abord courant électrique qui
permet de retirer les grosses poussière
puis la poudre de charbon carte les
contaminants comme les métaux lourds les
dioxines et les furanes et de la chaux
neutralise les gaz acides des filtres
bloque les deux poudres et les
particules fines et l'espace et les gaz
donc à la sortie non particules sont
beaucoup moins élevés étant donné que
nos dépisteurs en fait un travail et les
contaminations beaucoup moins élevé
parce que y ont traversé l'ensemble de
cette épuration
il faut le souligner la qualité de l'air
qui sort dépend aussi des déchets qui y
entrent les dioxines et les furanes
c'est parce qu'on brûle du plastique et
de zinc le plomb ou le mercure ça vient
aussi de ce qu'on jette
batteries des batteries d'auto les
balles et les piles qu'on peut retrouver
dans différents électronique
l'électronique entre tout ça ça peut
conduire les métaux toutes ces choses le
salamin d'une quantité quand même
important de contaminer que nous on doit
gérer à la sortie on est capable de
gérer mais ça nous donne une complexité
de plus
certains polluants sont mesurés en
continu pour les autres une firme
externe via mener des campagnes
d'échantillonnage deux fois par année
est récente
les appareils sont installés tour à tour
dans chaque cheminée pendant des heures
des filtres vont recueillir les
différents contaminants et bonne
nouvelle cette année l'incinérateur a
réussi à respecter toutes les normes
c'est une première depuis longtemps en
particulier pour le monoxyde de carbone
et pour vanessa you banks ce n'est pas
seulement une affaire de brûlures ou de
charbon
je n'y arriverais possède donc beaucoup
de monde derrière mu pourra travailler
là dessus beaucoup de régulation de
procédés pour salir 5 comme ça mais il
ya de la régulation il faut réguler leur
faut réguler la vitesse des gris lorsque
les décharges il ya plein de choses à
regarder dans son ensemble
résultat on est très fiers
respecter les normes avec des
équipements vieillissants c'est un défi
de tous les jours mais québec tient son
incinérateur
[Musique]
parce qu'il a des avantages sur le plan
de l'environnement et le premier c'est
de produire de l'énergie en fait oui
c'est carrément centrale thermique dans
certaines industries ont refusé les
écorces les dons vont utiliser du gaz
naturel de l'huile au importe
combustible et si notre constitue
principe a scellé des schèmes avec ces
déchets là on va générer une grande
quantité d'énergie combo réutiliser en
transformant de l'eau en vapeur
la papetière white birch un peu plus
loin consomme environ la moitié de la
vapeur l'autre moitié sera bientôt
acheminés vers le nouvel hôpital de
l'enfant jésus dans les deux cas ça
remplace de l'énergie qui auraient été
produites à partir de gaz naturel ou
d'autres combustibles
l'autre avantage de l'incinération c'est
qu'à défaut d'éliminer complètement les
déchets il en reste beaucoup moins la
sortie ce qu'on voit ici en fait ce
qu'on appelle là forcément hrc ski
europe ont brûlé dans l'otc les cendres
qui vont être amorcées par les grilles
de fond et avec les centres tous cas pas
brûlé dont principal en métal donc c'est
certain que si on met un évier on voit m
un
vélo ça va finir ici dans la fosse à
manches part parce que ça brûle recombu
de repos les métaux
le mâchefer est acheminé vers un
recycleur de métaux qui en récupère
environ 5000 tonnes par année ce qui
reste finit à l'enfouissement en bout de
ligne on va pour à peu près l'équivalent
de 20 à 25% 2 par rapport à ce qui est
en arrêt pour être incinérés
avant les travaux de modernisation
la ville de québec avait fait ses
calculs fermé l'incinérateur qui se
tourner vers l'enfouissement ce serait
bien pire en termes de gaz à effet de
serre
c'est aussi le calcul que l'europe a
fait l'incinération a le vent dans les
voiles et a détrôné l'enfouissement il
ya quelques années mais là bas comme ici
l'idéal ce serait de brûler uniquement
les vrais déchets ceux avec lesquels il
n'y a plus rien à faire
on sait tous que l'idée ce serait
d'avoir zéro déchet donc on veut
continuer à promouvoir le faire de
promouvoir le recyclage la réutilisation
le réemploi mais le déchet ultime nous
on veut pas canal+ mais ça risque de
déchets ultimes on doit faire quelque
chose puis on considère qu'elle s'est
quand même quelque chose qui intéressait
qu'un avenir au niveau du déchet ultime
l'incinérateur aura bientôt une nouvelle
annexe
la ville est en train de transformer sa
façon de récolter de trier et de traiter
les déchets
avec son exemple québec espère changer
la réputation de l'incinération en
général mais aussi de son propre
incinérateur ça reste une des machines
par contre si on garde ce qui se fait
dans les inspirateurs moderne au niveau
de l'épuration des gars versus d'art les
cheminées ses rimes technologies qui
sont employés donc la technologie
utilisée est encore à jour l'usiné
vieille halle avec les modernisations on
est capable de garder les standards de
qualité élevés de respecter les normes
construire des incinérateurs modernes
dans toute la province ça coûterait des
milliards de dollars
sur papier l'incinération a des
avantages
mais l'idée risque d'être difficile à
vendre
non
[Musique]
les gestes sont à la fois rapide et
précis ils sont répétés des milliers de
fois et à chaque geste ou presque on
génère des déchets que ce soit après le
service ou avant
quand tu enlèves la peau d'un poisson
quand on enlève le bout d'une carotte
quant à elle une patate et tout on
réalise paul à la maison on s'en
aperçoit un petit peu né dans un
restaurant multiplié sa part les
milliers de clients qu'on attend d'une
journée ou d'un bonne semaine ça fait
beaucoup de résidus
des résidus organiques que pierre moreau
et ses employés ne voulait plus mettre
aux poubelles
[Musique]
je suis de la génération qui a vu les
bacs bleus appareils tu un moment donné
dans notre vie mais tous mes employés
qui ont en moyenne dans la vingtaine les
autres vivent avec ça depuis toujours on
avait beaucoup de pression de nos jeunes
employés qui nous lie la restauration
trouve que vos efforts seront son port
sont pas magnifique
bien pas que la restauration que les
efforts à faire que ce soit au travail
ou à la maison des québécois génère
environ 2 millions de tonnes de résidus
organiques par année et on en récupère à
peine 20%
le plus souvent pour en faire du compost
leur est finie aux poubelles mais ce
n'est pas leur place parce qu à
l'enfouissement les matières organiques
émettent du méthane et à l'incinération
elles sont trop humide pour qu'on en
tire de l'énergie une partie du problème
c'est que les bacs bruns municipaux sont
souvent réservées aux résidences et aux
petits commerces
les autres doivent se payer leur propre
système de collecte
pierre moreau a fait le tour des options
disponibles dans plusieurs de ses
restaurants les matières organiques vont
maintenant dans un broyeur fait partie
de la recette développé par celui ci qu
une petite entreprise de québec les
résidus sont transformés en purée qui
stockée dans un réservoir
en attendant la collecte
notre technologie est installé au coeur
des opérations donc dès que le geste de
produire les déchets alimentaires se
fait à quelques pieds de l'oeil aux leur
boussole du cycle et on va donc pouvoir
mettre la matière tout de suite dans le
robot chacun nouveau rôle pour enfin
porter
il vend la pointe voit le problème des
matières organiques comme une occasion
d'affaires en allant les récupérer à la
source les très grands hôtels qu'on a
comme clients puis les foires
alimentaires on est là tu donnes ont
frôlé où on dépasse la demi tonne par
jour de déchets alimentaires malgré tous
les efforts de valorisation qui sont
faites en amont quand on sert trois
quatre cinq mille repas par jour c'est
difficile encore aujourd'hui le de le
dire je vais diminuer drastiquement ma
pertes alimentaires
[Musique]
depuis les tout débuts celui cycle
travail avec un fabricant de cuisines
commercial lui aussi basé à québec
parce qu'il fallait que l'appareil
s'intègrent bien aux autres équipements
des restaurants
[Musique]
ça prend les partenaires puissent a pas
un savoir faire nous on avait développé
savoir faire sur le le système en
parenthèse mais on savoir faire sur
comment
intégrer ce système là dans un appareil
pour en tirer le maximum le robot
actuellement prend l'espace d'une
poubelle c'est tout le remplace
le robot actuelle c'est un peu le bébé
de christian rivet il aura bientôt un
grand frère le prototype qui a été
fabriqué vise les épiceries qui génèrent
elles aussi des résidus organiques un
modèle qui sera mieux adapté à leur
réalité
il est beaucoup plus gros pour être
capable de prendre des plus grands
volumes plus des plus grosses matière
pas kiffer la morphologie est un petit
peu différente et un peu plus à
l'horizontale ça va occuper l'espace à
peu près d'un gros congélateur de
maisons lors un petit peu plus rôle
contrairement à celui qu'on a développé
pour les cuisine et à peine gros comme
un réfrigérateur qui prend pas de place
dans une cuisine
la matière recueillis par celui cycle
prend le chemin d'installation comme
celle centres de traitement de la
biomasse de la montérégie le ctv m
depuis 17 ans on y reçoit des résidus de
l'industrie agroalimentaire qui l a
d'excellents taux de récupération
entre débours de transformation donc des
moûts d'abattoirs des attrapes agressent
les alcools dégradé des matières résidus
de transformation alimentaire dont donc
tout ce qui se dégage par un procédé
physique ou chimie
de suture est faite pour savoir autant
des liquides que des solides donc la
tribune trémie de 60 mètres cubes dont
on conçoit des solides à l'intérieur du
bâtiment pression négative les matières
liquides douanes déchargée par une
conduite latéral benoît paré est en
train de convertir son usine à un
nouveau procédé la biométhanisation
avec le compost c'est l'autre avenue
pour les matières organiques
c'est aussi celle que préfère ceux du
cycle le principe ressemble un peu à la
digestion humaine
la nourriture contient deux grosses
molécules comme les sucres les gras ou
les protéines elles sont d'abord coupé
en morceaux puis digérées par des
bactéries qui vont générer une toute
petite molécule le méthane ce méthane
vont être injectés dans le réseau de
gazoducs d'énergie nrj rire étant
d'ailleurs son réseau de gazoducs pour
aller recueillir ce méthane il est
considéré comme du gaz naturel
renouvelable plus vert donc que celui
d'origine fossile
la digestion produit aussi une partie
solide qui sera transformé en engrais et
on s'attend à de bons résultats avec les
risques du des restaurants se matières
organiques qui se dégradent biens de
consommation qu'on appelle noble qui est
exempte de contaminants dans l' avantage
mashaie comme celle de sow lucic ce
matin qu'on peut facilement revaloriser
sous forme d'engrais biologiques par un
pot de geste en valeur ajoutée donc une
matière qui est riche à l'entrée ou à
refaire une gestion qui a des valeurs
agronomique plus élevées comme celle de
solutions paul
et la valeur des débouchés c'est crucial
pour une entreprise privée comme le ctv
m privés ou publics les usines de
biométhanisation ce compte pour
l'instant sur les doigts de la main
québec devrait avoir la sienne sous peu
et d'autres grandes villes ont des
projets d'usinés
et comme avec le compost la qualité de
ce qu'on en tire dépend avant tout de ce
qu'on récolte le défi de toutes les
solutions de valorisation des déchets
alimentaires c'est au jour qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec la contamination comment
on fait pour éviter la contamination
puis plus vite on prend la matière brute
qui est sorti d'une opération le
quelconque et de la mettre dans un
endroit sécurisé évidemment la pureté
c'est là qu'on voit le l'atteindre
c'est tout l'intérêt de récolter la
matière directement dans les cuisines
chez restos plaisirs la motivation de
départ était environnementale mais le
meilleur argument a été économique parce
qu'il faut aussi payer pour jeter bah
oui faut payer pour les poubelles les
poubelles du pays au poids ou à la levée
alors que l'ue vient de s'ouvrir tout ça
coûte cher c'est mathématique
dans ses quatre restaurants équipés par
celui cycle les déchets ont fondu de
moitié et les économies sont au rendez
vous
c'est comme entrepreneur on est on est
tous courent la vertu qu'on veut
améliorer mais il faut que quelque part
il ya un bénéfice économique pour le
faire on fait notre calcul économique
basé sur l'investissement la réduction
des déchets habituellement on a fait les
calculs avec les gentils haut du cycle
ça nous prend à peu près 2 1 à 2 ans et
demi récupérer l'investissement puis
après ça c'est des économies qu'on fait
[Musique]
la recette est rentable grâce au volume
de clientèle c'est moins vrai pour des
plus petits joueurs il faut des
solutions adaptées à chaque commerce
chaque industrie parce que le
gouvernement du québec a un objectif
ambitieux récupéré 70% des matières
organiques si 2030 et pour y arriver il
cherche à multiplier les initiatives
comme celle de solutions nous comme
d'autres ont fait notre part on amène
innovation la flexibilité et
l'efficacité mais ça prend aussi un
joueur comme le gouvernement ou les
paliers de gouvernement pour venir
donner des aides gouvernementales des
facilités pour que tout le monde aille
rapidement le défi qu'ont actuellement
c'est que les lois vont changer le temps
va jouer contre tout le monde et il va
falloir trouver des solutions à tous les
niveaux très rapidement puis le secret
séché au gouvernement
l'autre solution retenue par québec
c'est d'augmenter graduellement le coût
de l'enfouissement qui est relativement
bas en ce moment
l'idée c'est de rendre plus compétitive
la récupération des matières organiques
parce que ce n'est pas un secret pour
une entreprise c'est souvent l'argent
qu'elle dernier mot et faire des choix
plus verts ne devraient pas coûter plus
cher
[Musique]
tous les jours des centaines de camions
à déchets prennent la route à bord il y
a des ressources qu'on gaspille comme du
bois et du verre mais surtout un million
de tonnes de papier de carton et
plastique est assez de métal pour
construire deux ponts de québec
les camions déchargent directement dans
le fond de la fosse est impossible pour
nous de faire un tri
et s'est mélangée avec des matières
organiques et des déchets carrément
dangereux comme la peinture c'est un
gâchis auquel on note pas toujours
l'impression de contribuer et pourtant
c'est pas nous qui généreront les
déchets et des matières sont générés par
la population québécoise puis un accent
mélangé à d'autres matières font pas
leur donner une deuxième vie à karim ici
s'il ya une chose sur laquelle tous ceux
à qui on a parlé s'entendent c'est que
le québec a du ménage à faire dans ses
poubelles et les citoyens ont leur rôle
à jouer
qu'on doit vraiment s'il ya quelqu'un
qui l'a mis dans un bac dans un
conteneur fait qu'il ya une étape parce
que le citoyen va mettre dans son bac
une des villes qui est citée en exemple
c'est big fuel sur l'île de montréal il
y a dix ans elle partait de loin
on produisait le deuxième plus haut
quantité d'ordures à habitants sur l'île
de montréal comme les autres vide on
avait plusieurs collectes disponibles le
bac bleu collecte de feuilles à
l'automne mais c'est que l'acte était
pas utiliser de façon optimale en pente
par nos résidents
et quand ndjodo field parle
d'utilisation non optimale c'est que les
deux tiers des matières résiduelles
aller aux poubelles le tiers pour
recyclage est presque rien dans les
autres collectes
et keynes field a opté pour un modèle
payer pour jeter ici quand le chauffeur
s'arrête le système enregistre chaque
levée et enverra la facture au
propriétaire via son compte de taxes
le coût dépend à la fois de la taille du
bac et du nombre de lever par année mais
le vrai secret de cette collecte dite
intelligente c'est la façon de
l'implanter parce que bien avant de le
faire beaconsfield a consulté ses
citoyens elle a diversifié ses collectes
et fournit des bacs à compost pour la
cour on a incité les gens attendent
leurs feuilles et à laisser leur gazon
sur place et ça fonctionne et si en 2013
le terrain des pires on a mis petit à
petit certains éléments en place pour
permettre à nos résidents de mieux faire
mais rendu 2016 si on compare avec 2013
il ya eu une diminution de 51% par
habitant pour la quantité d'eau deux
enfants voués à l'enfouissement
la poubelle a diminué de moitié parce
que les résidents ont mieux profité des
autres collectes comme les encombrants
les résidus de jardin et de table et les
feuilles mortes
[Musique]
chaque automne certains résidants
choisissent de changer leur format de
poubelles
ça fait partie de la recette de
beaconsfield celle de forcer les gens à
réfléchir à ce qu'ils jettent et à
choisir comment
et la plupart des gens y ont trouvé leur
compte
en 2016 plus que trois quarts de risque
d'en payer moins cher grâce aux efforts
de mettre nos bacs d'ordures ou chemins
moins fréquemment alors ya eu une
diminution pour la majorité de nos
résidents malgré l'ajout du service
pour la ville moins de déchets ça coûte
moins cher à ramasser l'argent économisé
à financer les autres collectes
beaconsfield fait mieux qu'avant pour le
même prix pour quelques années elle est
passée la dernière place ou presque à la
première dans l'agglomération de
montréal
le modèle peut s'appliquer à d'autres
villes en particulier celles où il ya
beaucoup de maisons unifamiliales
chaque ville a sa réalité absolument
mais après discussion avec d'autres
villes avec toutes les questions que je
sus des villes au québec mais aussi au
canada c'est transposable à d'autres
réalités mais il faut tester ceci dans
votre environnement
et les réalités sont tellement
différentes qu'on peut difficilement
comparer les villes entre elles mais si
on regarde le sac poubelle moyen des
municipalités à l'intérieur en 2019 il y
avait encore 57 % de matières organiques
et 20 % de matières recyclables les
trois quarts du contenu devrait aller
ailleurs
[Musique]
dans les sites d'enfouissement les
déchets des municipalités s'ajoute à ce
que jette les commerces les hôpitaux les
tours à bureaux les condos et les petits
entrepreneurs en construction
c'est sur l'ensemble des déchets du
québec que le bape s'est penché pour
voir si on peut faire mieux dans les 20
prochaines années
il ya plusieurs décisions qui relèvent
des villes et des gouvernements comme de
choisir entre l'enfouissement et
l'incinération
ou encore de multiplier les collectes
pour trier les matières
[Musique]
il faut aussi revoir la façon de
concevoir les produits de les
transporter et de les consommer tout ça
prend évidemment du temps mais à court
terme la solution c'est de mettre aux
poubelles uniquement ce qui va aux
poubelles
parce que ce n'est pas aux responsables
de l'incinérateur de faire le tri à
notre place
chose rare ans inévitablement dans les
faux on de ce côté là il ya peut-être un
peu d'éducation encore à faire auprès
des ja auprès des citoyens sur qu'est-ce
qu'ils vont dans les poubelles de
recyclage ou à l'écossé
et c'est le même son cloche du côté des
sites d'enfouissement
il ya des matins qui pourraient être
utilisés valoriser recyclées mais
malheureusement une fois que j'ai
mélangé avec d'autres matières pendant
la collecte et puis que s'est rendu ici
c'est déjà trop tard donc c'est vraiment
misé sur le comportement des gens et en
amont du système en amont pour limiter
les matières pour être qu'on pourrait
donner une deuxième vie à ma clique et
qu'il soit acheminé ici dans l'autre
ça peut sembler anodin mais investir du
temps pour mieux utiliser le bac à
recyclage ou à compost ou encore les
points de dépôt comme les écocentres ça
réglerait déjà une bonne partie du
problème et ça permet de s'y attaquer
dès maintenant